hi there today we'll look at super masks
in super position again so this is part
2 of this paper by Mitchell woodsman and
Vivek ram anujan and here's a reason why
there's a part two so after yesterday's
video on this paper I I like I couldn't
sleep because I really felt that I had
left out some important aspects that I
wanted to touch on during the video now
sometimes during videos I look at the
clock and I'll realize like oh crap the
videos already like an hour long and I
know people are watching on to X speed
anyway but still it's like too long and
I need to wrap it up really soon and
what I felt were pretty important
messages about this paper got lost so
specifically I want to address three
different things first of all they have
like a formal analysis not a formal but
a a kind of more rigorous analysis of
what their modified G objective does and
I also want to give some intuition in
that because I felt I felt I really
hadn't done a good job at that the
second part is that the two different
ideas right here being the super masks
and the super position and I think my
opinion is sort of that these are two
separate things and they really have
nothing to do with each other and I
think that didn't really come through
last video and the third one being the
broader impact statement of this paper
which I you know I usually kind of gloss
over it and go like haha but I hear
there is an important point to it so um
yeah we'll get to that alright so again
not a new paper today I realize this but
I think it's worth kind of diving deeper
into this paper which is a very cool
paper you know so so don't don't get me
wrong right here and I feel mostly I
have done a good part at explaining it
like literally lying awake ok so let's
go to the first point we had this so if
you hadn't seen the first video super
mass and super position basically says
that we want to do lifelong learning
and we won't do lifelong learning by
lifelong learning is the task where you
have a bunch of tasks in sequence and
you learn them in sequence so one after
the other and basically the goal is to
not forget tasks once new you learn new
tasks and this model does it by always
building one of these super masks for
each task that is applied to the same
randomly initialized base neural network
each time and you know by by keeping the
super mask around you won't forget the
task and then at inference time if
you're given the tasking just to
retrieve the mask if you're not given
the tasks you can do this superposition
trick where you apply all the masks in a
superposition and then you look at sort
of the gradient of an entropy function
in order to decide which task reduces
the entropy the most so which task is
the most certain about a particular data
point and that you you kind of infer
that that's the task you're going to go
with so instead of the entropy which is
you know well reasoned they had this
other objective they call G & G
basically looks at the it's really
strange it looks at the superfluous
neurons so they also add these
superfluous neurons these s neurons
right here and they they the G objective
will only look at the S neurons in order
to decide whether or not that's the
correct task and it's basically just the
log some X of the S neurons and we had
some intuition about them being you know
all small and so on them being like
outlier detectors but there is an entire
chapter in the appendix where the
authors do a sort of more in-depth
theoretical analysis of that which you
know I it's not not necessary to do this
for them so I really enjoy I enjoyed
reading that and that gave me sort of
the better intuition of what this G
objective does so here they say the aim
is not to formally prove properties of
the algorithm
rather we hope that a more mathematical
language may prove useful in extending
intuition okay
so again that's that's pretty cool so
they start off by saying you have your
neural network is basically W and the D
sorry D it's it's this Phi right here
and the W are the last layers weights
which compute your lockets so Y is going
not to be your class but Y is going to
be your lockets and P is going to be the
probability vector over your class which
if the you calculate this via a soft max
is going to be the following expression
right here if you have a mask right then
at least in the last layer you can in
you can infer it as this right here so
you multiply the mask by the last these
weights and then that gives you your
lockets so they say here with they
initialize the weights right here
actually they initialize D they have no
bias term and they initialize the
weights by these constant so plus minus
this constant it's not really necessary
to do that but they do it right here
makes the analysis also a bit easier and
I guess it just works more well if you
have these masks in superposition of
course you want to add all of these
masks with the respective alpha
weighting factor then multiplied by the
weights and that gives you your log it's
so note that this this doesn't
necessarily only only have to be the
last layers weights right here you can
view that as any sort of weights of the
neural network if you formulate this Phi
correctly so you don't think that they
only apply the mask to the last layer
they do apply the mask to the entire
thing all right now the the important
part here is what happens if we look at
the derivative of G with respect to one
of the alphas and take the maximum
negative derivative of that G which is
that mysterious function that only looks
at the at
at the superfluous neurons so what they
want they kind of construct this GE by
principle what they say is we want a
function G that mimics the supervised
loss right we want a function G that is
kind of equal like the supervised loss
if we had the task ID and that's that's
pretty cool because um you know the the
supervised loss you sort of need all the
information you need the label you need
you need all the other you need the task
ID so the supervised loss is unavailable
but we want a function G that in its
gradient mimics the supervised loss so
they go about constructing this right
here
they say lemma first lemma it's possible
to construct a function G such that the
gradient matches the gradient from the
supervised loss for all s neurons so for
all these superfluous neurons
specifically we want that the gradient
with respect to the lockets if the
gradient to the log is equal that means
the gradient to all the rest of the
network is equal because the rest of the
network goes through the log it's write
the gradient through the log it's is
equal to the gradient of the supervised
loss to the log it's for all the
superfluous neurons and zero otherwise
so they say the zero otherwise is pretty
easily done in math you know gently set
it to zero and in the actual code which
you can achieve like this where M
indicates the superfluous neurons so
this is just a sachet multiplied here
and the other ones are detached so there
is no gradient flowing this is the
property that we only look at the
superfluous neurons and now we are going
to show that the gradient is going to be
equal so they say if you had the
supervised loss which means if you have
the label then this would be your cross
entropy loss
so you cross it divides into this part
where you need the label and then this
part here you don't need the label now
you can pretty say pretty much say look
if the label is certainly going to be
one of not disapper fewest neurons
because the superfluous neurons are
superfluous they are never the correct
neuron so this is always going to be you
know not they not the neurons we look at
so the gradient certainly this is always
going to be zero because we never we
wherever the gradient is flowing that's
not where the where this is one so the
gradient of any superfluous neuron is
just this thing right here and that's
exactly why they build the function G so
the function G has this exact gradient
the function G if you derive it has that
same gradient as the supervised loss for
the superfluous neurons okay so it's
it's sort of magic but it's not you know
it's not magic so they need two more
assumptions here to have to get the
following properties so the for the
first property now because now we want
to have G be identifying the correct
task
so we've already constructed G now we
want to show that if we really do this
the gradient with respect to the alphas
then if we do it for a wrong task for
the tasks that it's not the task of that
particular data point that goes into
computing G then we'll get a value
that's probably lower than zero however
if we plug in if we derive but with
respect to the alpha of the correct task
then we get a gradient a negative
gradient that's higher than zero okay so
we're now going to prove that this with
high probability really allows us to
distinguish the correct task from the
wrong task and we need two assumptions
right here
the assumption one is we assume that the
mask learned on task I will be
independent from the data from task J if
the task data is from task J then this
are independent random variables okay so
it sort of means that the tasks
themselves are kind of independent but
it's not it's it's not the same
requirement but you can think of in in
the case of per muted M nest or so this
is some it's given except if you
consider this kind of frequency of
brightness and so on but if you have
independent task I think that this is
given that means that the features right
here and the masks are independent
variable if if the data is from task J
then the features and the masks from
task I or independent variable sorry the
second assumption you need is that we
assume that a negative weight and the
positive weight are equally likely to be
masked out okay
so this again you can think of with some
regularity this is certainly going to be
to be given in a randomly initialized
neural network note that when the
features are 0 which will be the case
for 0 mean random features yeah so um
yeah before I said this was your neural
network this is your random neural
network right and then you mask that and
so on
if this is a randomly initialized neural
network then you can make a case that
the expected features of those will be 0
it doesn't need to be the case but you
can you can construct it such that it is
so if you have the two things right if
you have those two things then you can
prove the following if the data X comes
from task J then when you derive by an
alpha that's not of task J you get a
number that's smaller than 0 in
expectation and here the crucial part is
you reframe this gradient
refrain refrain and what you'll see is
that this here comes out so this is a
sum and each element of the sum is going
to be greater or equal to zero which
means that this thing is greater equal
to 0 which means the negative thing is
smaller than zero in lemma h1 now we're
going to look at lemma h1 to get an
intuition of what's going on right here
so lemma h1 says if J is the true task
and I is not equal to J then this
quantity here is greater than 0 alright
I restarted my tablet and we are back so
what's kind of the the intuition behind
why this quantity here would be greater
or equal to 0 and honestly in order to
make it a bit easier I first want to
look at whenever I equals J so whenever
J is the true task and then I equals J
then we can sort of think of the
opposite like why why this should be
smaller or equal to 0 so consider this
this is the Randi feature of the network
of U right
and then the UV connects that to the to
the mask at point V and the mask at
point at that point UV is either 0 or 1
depending on the training so this this
guy right here that's going to be D from
the initialization but the mask is going
to be 0 or 1 depending on whether that
feature contributes sorry whether this
entire thing here contributes positively
to the task or not so the secret right
here why we can make claim that this is
greater or lower than 0 is going to be
that the mask can only be 0 or 1 it
cannot be negative 1 right so if the
mask is 0 then obviously this thing is
to be zero however if the mask is one
what does it mean if the mask is one
that means that this this entire feature
right here let's call it f is positively
impacting is positively contributing to
this particular neuron right here so if
the mask is one this is this it means
the addition of that feature more of
that feature makes that log it go up
okay so if the mask is one during
training it means that the the feature
positively contributes to the task so if
we look at the gradient with respect to
dysfunction with respect to the the log
it and the function basically means it's
just measured measures how high these
superfluous logins are then what what
why do we find a negative interaction
there because if you look at the neural
network and you forward pass and this
particular feature is important and you
look at the lost G and you backward pass
through the log it's if it is smaller
than zero that means that there is a
negative interaction right here so that
basically means that if we make this
feature higher then in this case we make
this G function go lower okay and that
is the case for the correct test because
if this is the correct task and the mask
is learned adequately that means it
should assign a low weight to the
superfluous neuron whenever the input
features you know or of that task and so
it makes sense that this here would be a
negative number because what we want if
the mask deems the feature important in
a positive sense we want that if the
feature goes up G go
down and that is exactly why we have the
negative interaction right here right so
the negative comes from this being
negative
I hope this sort of makes sense so if
the mask is one the mask says basically
if that feature goes up the loss goes
down now GE is a measure of the
superfluous neurons the superfluous
neurons should be small if the loss is
small so if this is really from the task
and this feature is really useful that
means if we increase the feature the G
function should go down and therefore
this product here is going to be most
likely negative okay and the contrary is
you know analogous right here if this is
not of this task the mask can either be
0 or 1 right if it's 0 then this
quantity is 0 however if it's 1 it's
more likely that the that there the
feature here because it's AI is not the
correct task which basically means that
this feature it is for a different task
it is good for a different task so the
mask of that different task says it's
good right here and we have no reason to
believe that this would decrease the
loss of the loss of this particular data
point in this task so it's kind of the
inverse reasoning if you look at the
actual derivation here it's fairly long
and it goes over the cases of the
interactions between actually this
initialization and the mask so the
initialization can be positive or
negative as you can see right here and I
think I just think that the intuition
here is that the superfluous neurons
react differently to a data point of the
trained task because they have been kind
of made to decrease for that task and
for that particular mask as they do for
when the data point doesn't match the
mask when a data point doesn't match the
mask there is no reason for the lockets
of the superfluous neurons to be low and
if the data point task does match the
mask there is ample reasons for those to
be low I hope that sort of makes sense
it is sort it's a bit more of an
intuition but if you really want to dig
into it look at the derivation right
here okay second point is the fact that
the masks and the super positions don't
really have to do anything with each
other and that's you know I've I've said
throughout the video like remember these
tasks are super easy yada yada yada
so let me make it clear in this in this
diagram right here the super masks these
are simply a way to train a neural
network in a crude way right I don't
think there is
you know this distinction between mask
and network I don't really like that
much because ultimately what you're
doing is simply you're training a neural
network in a kind of weird way okay the
fact that you always use the same
underlying you know gray neural network
doesn't really matter right here it's
still what you do in these super masks
raining is you provide a severely over
parametrized Network and then the mask
simply gets to choose which weights to
mix rather than you get to adjust the
weights if you adjust the weights
usually get more accurate than with the
mask but it's sort of like a quantized
neural network that you train right here
so that's the super mask thing again I
don't think it's important that the
underlying network is always the same
the only advantage you have is it saves
space because these masks are very small
the super masks on the other hand this
idea that you overlay all of the masks
together and then you look at where this
at the gradient of the entropy and you
look at which of the of the mixing
factors the gradient pulls the most
that's a different idea and the question
here is wouldn't that isn't that in the
henan doesn't really depend on the masks
or doesn't it and the you know the
hypothesis would be that if I simply
train you know three different neural
networks for three different tasks could
I not do the same superposition trick
like could I not just add all of them
with a respective alpha look at the
entropy calculate the gradient with
respect to each of the alphas of the
entropy and then decide which task it is
you know don't need masks simply mix
neural networks in superposition so I
did it and I actually tried there code
is available so big props for their code
being available
I tried their code it's actually very
few changes and I'm going to append my
live coding of this at the end of this
video so if you wanna if you are
interested in watching that you can do
so but you know the outcome is if I
train neural networks that I have I've
you know done super quick and
initialized them wrongly probably and
all but if I train these neural net if I
could train the masks you get to like
92% accuracy in their tasks in each of
the tasks and then also in the average
if I train the actual neural networks I
get to a higher accuracy like
ninety-three something it doesn't matter
it's just higher okay so that's
hypothesis one as the training masks is
just a way of training neural networks
the fact that the masks and the network
training itself are that close I think
is a testament to how easy these tasks
are like how easy m-net amnesties I'm
going to also hypothesize that if the
task gets harder and harder and I don't
mean ten class imagenet I mean at the
housing class imagenet then these masks
are going to degrade severely versus
training the actual neural network I
might be wrong I mean you can over
parameterize really heavily and they
will still work okay but in any case I
trade the trained these neural networks
and they reached higher accuracy and
then I did the exact same thing I laid
them in superposition to determine what
task it is and I could achieve the exact
same results so here in their example
they have a hundred percent task
classification accuracy
and I reach the exact same thing code
worked I'm not going to try to scale
this up to 250 or 2,500 and tasks but
I'm going to assume that with you know
tuning and stuff that it's going to work
about equally well you could make an
argument that the masks being sparser
they might be differentiated from each
other more accurately but I'm not sure
maybe but it's it's not a cool it's not
a qualitative difference right so these
two things are really two separate ideas
that find their way together in this
paper but ultimately have not much to do
with each other
okay at least that's from what I can
tell I might I might be wrong here and I
might be wrong with respect to their G
objective and whatnot and you know but I
think that that these are two cool ideas
but they can be applied independently so
the last thing I want to look at is
their broader impact statement right
here now there is a reason so usually I
kind of track this broader impact
statement because I think this this is
this here is sort of a fundamental
research right this is fundamental
machine learning research we do
architecture to multitask learning tasks
isn't really important as long as we
have kind of same tasks right here
uncorrelated and so on the same hardness
and I've also made the point that it's
really important for these tasks to be
the same hard for this to work in this
place a roll right here so and they do
they do describe some of this in this
conclusion with you know limitation that
we observed has to do with task identity
inference when models are not well
calibrated models that are overly
confident for the wrong task ok so in
order for them to infer the correct task
they the sort of so if you look at your
entropy of the
models for the tasks that means he's
gonna select the model that is the most
sure about the task this only works if
the tasks are equally hard okay if one
task is much much harder than the other
task this other task is always going to
say well I'm really confident about this
one because the task is just easier it's
going to be it's going to train a neural
network it's generally more confident
and you're going to miss classify a lot
of the tasks so so here what does this
have to do with a broader impact
statement if you look at the broader
impact statement what they say right
here so they say a goal of continued
learning self manly task with a single
model however it is not exactly clear
what qualifies as a single model
therefore a concrete objective has
become to learn many tasks as
efficiently as possible
we believe that sub sub is a useful step
in this direction however there are
consequences to more efficient models
both positive and negative so this is
sort of what the community does so there
are three things that I've seen so far
and broader impacts a first you some
people say this is not applicable to us
which I agree for most fundamental
research broader I like the broader
impact statement is supposed to be what
does this particular method how will
this influence broader society so not
applicable completely valid for most of
these research papers because guess what
you can use any method to do good or to
do bad and that's that's the second
second part second method is basically
use you just say Jim generic statements
how you can do good and bad and usually
you can't relate it to your particular
method in the paper right because your
method is I don't know like my faster
convergence rate of SGD but and and so
what do you do is you just go one level
up you go up the levels it's always like
optimization can be used for good and
for bad I mean that's still kind of a
bit vague and then you go up further
well optimization can do more machine
and machine learning can be used to do
good in that for example face
recognition and things like this so you
just go up the levels and that's what
they essentially do here and that's what
you know most people have defaulted to
it's like okay so you know our model
here is you know we it basically one can
train more efficient models and then
they simply highlight what more
efficient models can do efficient models
require less compute if engines model by
Iran on the end device if models are
more efficient and large-scale research
is not limited to wealthier institutions
by the way I also the broader impact
statement I believe should be the impact
on society and not really on the
research community itself so also this
this is a bit shaky with respect to
because I'm really regarding what the
broader impact statement should be this
is not my opinion I'm I'm trying to
reflect everything I've read of guidance
about what the broader impact statement
should be by the way there is also
method method 3 which is to simply tell
me more about your paper in the broader
impact statement which I guess is the
smart method because the broader impact
statement can be before the before the
references so it's in the main part and
people are required to read it not like
the appendix reviewers are not required
to read the appendix reviewers are
required to read the broader impact
statement so I guess the smart authors
will just try to cloak more information
about their model in terms of a broader
impact statement I guess well whether
that's smart is a different discussion
but here they just it's it's already
defaulting right these it's already the
default people simply go level up level
up level up until we can you know say
something generic and we will also
highlight and discuss the negative
consequences of models which can
efficiently learn many tasks and
efficient models in general when models
are more efficient they're also more
available and less subject to
regularization as a stuff and study of
result for instance when a high impact
model is released an institution will
hopefully be accompanied by a model card
analyzing the bias and in
the use of the model by contrast if
anyone is able to train a powerful model
this may no longer be the case resulting
in a proliferation of model with harmful
biases or intended use taking the United
States for instance bias can be harmful
as models show disproportionately more
errors for already marginalized groups
furthering existing deeply rooted
structural racism this this is like will
technology this is basically a statement
about technology and so why why do I
have a particular not issue but why do I
pick this broader impact statement they
even rip this here this is this gender
shades paper right where people went and
they looked at these commercial api's
for face recognition I think that's the
paper yeah gender shades so if you have
a face recognizer they realize they
divided people up by I think gender and
race so you know yet like they they
build for groups or I haven't I haven't
I've just looked at the paper but I'm
understanding that they divided people
up into groups which I find arbitrary to
have the these two axes race and gender
but okay you can do that and they
discover that these commercial api's
have different accuracy for the
different groups right and that
basically our point is that you know
these commercial API is if they're
offered for all humans they should work
equally well for all humans now now you
may be out see what it has to do with
this paper
well this paper is in the business of
doing multitask learning so it is very
valuable to actually frame the the task
for example like this is an example if
you frame the task of multitask learning
like face recognition on different
groups of people as a multitask learning
problem you have you know group group
one right here group two group
three and then if at inference time so
you can build you know good models for
each of the group at inference time
you're given an image and you're trying
to infer first which group is that from
and then take the appropriate classifier
that would be you know that would be a
good a hypothetical classifier for this
thing now what do we know about this
thing this thing is fails if the tasks
aren't equally hard all so in in
specifically if if for one group let's
say for group 3 the the task is way
harder because you have less data I
guess the one of the main problems there
is that the data sets are not equally
balanced if you have less data for that
then the task becomes de facto harder
and the model is less sure about the
task which means that it's a double
whammy so not only is the model itself
less accurate but these the input data
point if the person is actually of group
3 is less likely to be classified
correctly into the correct model at to
begin with so you know for all d 4i I've
had my share of of comments on the video
I made and I still maintain that
societal bias can comes about by data
set but for all the people saying there
are models that exaggerate existing
biases in models this would be like if
there is any or any applicability of
these broader impact statement
guidelines this would be the paper right
it's this right here is an actual system
that if I have different classifiers and
I combine them with this method it will
double punish the classifier that is
less sure that is less accurate because
that is also going to be the one with
the higher entropy therefore not as much
selected if I give a data point of that
particular task and so this is like a
I'm not criticizing the method here like
by all mean like this is a cool method
where you can recognize that this
happens and
to calibrate accordingly but if there
was ever any straight ball for a broader
impact statement I would you know this
is it and this I'm not I'm not trying
I'm not saying that these these authors
didn't do that for a reason I believe
that look it's been whatever not even
half a year since we've started with
these general broader impact statements
and everybody is already defaulting to
simply say technology good technology
bad that's that's that people aren't
even thinking and so this right this is
one of the reasons why I simply find
these broader impact statements to be
not that like not a good idea because
there is a default answer and people are
just putting it here even in like when
there is an actual obvious immensely
obvious thing that they even they even
cited like the basis for that so you
know that's sort of my take on this I
again I enjoyed this paper the code is
is available everything is good about
this this paper I'm not even the fact
that these are you know I think these
are kind of two separate these are
combined it cool they're analyzed
formally in theory there's intuition
given all good so don't get me wrong
that this is not like trashing this
paper it's just I felt I had something
more to say and I think that was it so
yeah I'll see you next time with the new
paper okay so our goal here is going to
be to change this code to not use masks
as mixtures but actually use neural
networks with real weights as as
mixtures and in superposition with each
other okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to train the different neural networks
and then use this kind of superposition
trick to figure out which tasks a data
came from so let's have a look at the
code right here and there's a bunch of
helper code and if we go down through
everything you'll see that this is the
amnesty muted data set so each each task
is basically a random permutation of
amnesty and if you execute I believe
this here and then you train the model
and right now it's for five tasks but I
guess that's going to be enough for now
yeah so if we get some good signal here
I guess it's a matter of of doing kind
of engineering and plumbing and tuning
if until you get it up to whatever two
hundred or two thousand tasks though I
might be wrong there so this is training
and I certainly sort of had a look at
the code but I haven't actually tried
this yet so the thing the model is built
here you see there's this multitask
fully connected which has these
different layers right here and it's
built by these multi task masks linear
models now the multi task masks linear
models are defined right here so it's
basically a linear model as you can see
it's derived from a linear from a linear
module and it has a parameter called num
tasks and then it has a parameter scores
which I guess is are these these masks
right here and the scores I'm going to
guess are always going to be multiplied
by the weights here in the forward so
you can see there in forward you get the
weights from the alphas oh yeah this is
the superimposed alright so if we know
the task ID down here we get this subnet
and we are going to multiply it with the
weights if we don't know the task ID we
want to get these alphas so the alphas
are going to be one over
number of tasks at the beginning we're
then going to multiply each of the
alphas with the weights and with that
we're going to get this subnet mask
right here so we need to know what this
self dot stacked is so the self dot
stacked is getting right here in this
cash mask were simply stacking these
this get subnet for all of these things
so our plan is going to be that this
subnet right here is going to be the
actual weights of the neural network
okay and not just the not just the mask
and then we don't need to actually
multiply it with the weight we can just
just forget about the weight obviously
and just train the subnet so for the
subnet as you can see here you have this
get subnet thing and that's an autograft
function which basically means in the
forward pass you want to discretize it
and in the backward pass this is a
straight through estimator so our first
task is going and this here should be
done now my laptop is stopped breathing
so we've trained five tasks and now we
can run inference on that so this is
when the task is given real quick you
can see task one 92% 92% 92% 92% so we
have a an overall performance of ninety
two point four four percent then when
the task is not given we have two things
to evaluate whether or not basically how
good we are overall and whether or not
we get the tasks correct
of course the tasks are at is a pretty
requirement so we have a hundred percent
task inference accuracy okay so um we
don't we don't okay we can we could
evaluate this here but you can already
see that but from last time there's like
no difference from the performance of
the when the task is given it's always
being able to infer the task we want to
check out the same thing so we want to
change first of all this get
that this is where it these scores are
discretized now given that these scores
are going to be end to end up being our
actual weights we won't we don't do that
we simply return the scores now this is
it this is pretty pointless right now
but we'll keep it just to be as close as
possible to the two that now mask in it
this is where we initialize the mask now
this is climbing uniform and it has some
thing but we want probably we want to
train the neural network to be
initialized you know as we know it so
let's try what what are other
initialized function so in it dot what
do we have here do we have what's
usually I don't even know normal
solve yeah that that sounds about right
that sounds about right
all right all right so scores and yeah
let's try this this could this could I
break everything right if you initialize
wrong will you get like dumb results so
okay
signed constant yadda yadda yadda where
is that used huh
okay oh that's also initializing
something so we calculate the gain and
then okay this doesn't seem good we'll
just keep it hey why not why not why not
just keep it at that all right
so cool oh yeah this is for the weight
anyway we won't use the weight at all of
this layer we'll just use our own
weights so here we have these stacked
okay we get the scores that's all good
like I'm pretty happy with that I'm
pretty happy with this mask in it that
we make our parameters so these are
going to be our different neural net
that we train this all looks good the
alphas look good now the only thing we
wanna do honestly is just to have not
the wait times the subnet here but the
subnet as such like this is this it
do we now train actual neural networks I
I have my doubts
honestly like there should be no this
should be it mm-hmm yeah yeah let's just
try it like weird you're gonna get a
mistake somewhere like a crash nope nope
okay all right it's raining
so for real like these scores right here
the fact what made them a mask is that
we discretize them right here so we made
them into a mask right here we're not
doing that anymore so we're just
training floats and then we're also not
multiplying it by the weight we are just
using those floats which means that we
are using the a basically a neural
network and then here the bias I was
worried about the bias but the bias is
always zero as you can see here so the
bias is always false yeah
so we're training five different neural
networks for five different tasks and
you know according to my hypothesis
these mask things are just kind of crude
quantized ways of training neural
networks and if if my hypothesis is
correct this here is going to turn out
probably even better than this masked
thing
okay so last task training right here
laptop starting to breathe good laptop
fast laptop very nice come on come on
come on
and we were done so again we have an
average top one performance of ninety
two point did I even oh no I ran this
right here okay like that's the exact
same number it was last time so we need
to run inference again and if we're
given the task ID then we are at ninety
three point nine percent so we increase
slightly which might just be due to the
fact that we initialize terribly
terribly okay so what does it say about
our task inference accuracy maybe
there's some masks here set model tasks
the alphas are two one nope no we're
good we're good
task inference accuracy 100% and I'm
going to guess well with the task
inference accuracy being 100% I'm going
to guess this here will give us the
exact same number
I like the 93.7% so yeah 93.9% so I'm
you know I'm going to say right here
that the on the super masks and the
super position really are two separate
ideas right you it's it's because the
paper is like it sounds cool and all
with the super mask in super position
but this inference using the super
position and then the entropy to decide
is really one idea and training
different super map the the advantage in
using super mask is of course at the
model is way smaller so you can remember
it much more easily but also you know
the it's really different if there's
there's nothing to do with the super
position yeah all right so I'm going I'm
going to guess this also works for you
know 200 tasks and whatnot the higher
order of tasks so I think that's it and
we're done here